you got two mindsets one of them is what  we're the best the other one is what  we're good but I think we got to kind of  I still think we got work to do right  the author says a person who thinks like  this if you are right and you're the  best guess what you kill everybody as a  competitor  but if you're wrong what happens  you're going out of business  then he comes over here and it says this  mindset the person's like I just think  we're not there yet guys I think we got  to do this we're good but I think we got  to improve this we got to call the  client one more time this mindset he  says  if you're right  that's great  if you're wrong that's great  did you get the question on what he's  saying both ways you're better off  betting here a lot of people in the  marketplace were here  the last one two three four five ten  years we're the best we're the best  we're the best  hubris born of success you think it's  because of you and you cannot lose